Tyra: LAST SEASON ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
ADRIANNE CURRY WENT FROM
WAITRESSING IN
JOLIET, ILLINOIS,
TO TOP MODEL
NOW IN DEMAND BY REVLON,
TOP MAGAZINES AND DESIGNERS.
NOW WE'VE DISCOVERED
A NEW GROUP OF UNKNOWNS,
LIKE SHANDI,
STRAIGHT FROM STOCKING SHELVES
AT A MISSOURI WALGREENS,
YOANNA, WHO WAS ONCE
50 POUNDS HEAVIER,
BETHANY, EAGER TO PROVE
THAT HER SEXINESS
CAN BE HIGH FASHION
AND CAMILLE, A FASHION STUDENT
WHOSE COOL CONFIDENCE
RATTLES HER ROOMMATES.
LAST WEEK,
ALL 12 WANNABE MODELS
ARRIVED IN NEW YORK CITY.
I'M NOT WASTING ANY TIME.
I'M THROWING YOU
STRAIGHT ON A RUNWAY.
J.: PERSONALLY,
I THINK YOU ALL SUCKED.
Tyra: AFTER SETTLING INTO
THEIR SUPER FLY SOHO CRIB,
PERSONALITIES BEGAN TO EMERGE.
Camille: MAYBE I'M JUST
A LITTLE MORE EDUCATED
THAN SOME OF THE OTHER GIRLS.
Tyra: JENASCIA OVERSLEPT
HER PHOTO SHOOT.
Jenascia: I DON'T KNOW HOW
THIS HAPPENED.
Mercedes: IT'S SURVIVAL
OF THE FITTEST.
JENASCIA DIDN'T WAKE UP.
THAT'S HER OWN DAMN FAULT.
Jenascia: BITCHES.
Nigel: YOU ARE GONNA BE NUDE.
Tyra: AS THE OTHER GIRLS
STRIP DOWN,
ANNA STAYED COVERED UP.
AND IN THE FIRST ELIMINATION...
Eric: THE HEAD BOB
AT THE END SEEMED CONTRIVED.
Tyra: ANNA WAS SENT HOME.
11 GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
Jenascia: WHEN I TAKE
OFFENSE, YOU'VE REALLY,
REALLY, REALLY PISSED ME OFF.
Xiomara: RIGHT, RIGHT, RIGHT.
Jenascia: AND I'LL LET YOU KNOW.
I AM THE SHORTEST GIRL
IN THE HOUSE.
LAST WEEK I WAS ALMOST CUT.
Tyra: JENASCIA.
Jenascia: I DON'T WANNA
DO THAT AGAIN.
THAT WASN'T FUN.
♪♪♪
Camille: THE REAL WORLD
IS NOT EASY.
THE MODELING INDUSTRY
TRUST ME, YOU'RE GETTING THERE
EARLY IN THE MORNING.
YOU'RE WAITING ALL THE WAY
INTO NIGHT.
EVEN AT HOWARD UNIVERSITY,
WHEN WE DO A FASHION SHOW,
AND YOU'RE CONFINED IN, LIKE,
YOU KNOW, THE AUDITORIUM...
ALPINE MUSIC HAS SOME REALLY
GOOD ADS, TOO.
I'M SORRY.
I'M AN ADVERTISING MAJOR.
Bethany: MM-HMM.
Camille: OKAY,
SEE THAT RIGHT THERE?
I WORKED ON THAT AD CAMPAIGN.
THAT IS MY AD CAMPAIGN
RIGHT THERE.
Bethany: CAMILLE--
WHERE DO YOU START
WITH THIS ONE?
SHE'S VERY HIGH-MAINTENANCE,
AND SHE SAYS THAT SHE'S NOT,
BUT SHE IS.
Camille: YEAH, I CAN WORRY
ABOUT MYSELF, BUT I CAN WORRY
ABOUT ME, ME, ME.
I DON'T--I'M NOT A SELFISH,
YOU KNOW, PERSON.
Yoanna: I DON'T KNOW
WHERE CAMILLE COMES FROM,
AND I REALLY DON'T LIKE CAMILLE.
WELL, I'M GONNA BE QUIET NOW
BECAUSE I'M GONNA MEDITATE
FOR THE EVENING.
Camille: CAN I SEE
YOUR ROSARY?
Yoanna: YEAH.
LIVING WITH CAMILLE IS PROBABLY
THE MOST EXHAUSTING EXPERIENCE
I HAVE EVER ENCOUNTERED.
ECCH.
♪♪♪
Shandi: I DO WANNA DO
ANOTHER PHOTO SHOOT, THOUGH.
Xiomara: I CAN'T WAIT.
I LOVE PHOTO SHOOTS.
IT'S, LIKE, MY FAVORITE.
Shandi: MM-HMM, ALL DAY LONG.
Xiomara: IT'S OUR TIME
TO TRANSFORM.
Shandi: XIOMARA HAS BECOME
A REALLY GOOD FRIEND OF MINE.
SHE MADE THIS KINDA NICKNAME
FOR US, LIKE, "THE U.D."
WE'RE THE UNDERDOGS
OF THE GROUP.
Xiomara: THE UNDERDOG.
BECAUSE SHANDI AND I
ARE HANGING OUT IN THE CUT,
BUT WHEN IT COMES TIME
TO PERFORM,
WE'RE GONNA KICK YOUR BEHIND.
Shandi: I DID NOT COME FROM
"MI-SSOURI"OR "MISS-OURAH"
AND A WALGREENS TO COME UP HERE
AND SIT ON MY ASS.
I'M GONNA DO ANYTHING TO, LIKE,
MAKE THE CHANGE IN MY LIFE,
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN SO TIRED
OF EVERYTHING BEFORE.
♪♪♪
April: WE ARE FINALLY HITTING
THE GYM.
WE'RE GOING TO A PLACE
OF PHYSICAL WORSHIP.
Martin: HOW ARE YOU GUYS
DOING?
MY NAME IS MARTIN SNOW,
THE OWNER OF THIS GYM.
IT'S THE WATERFRONT BOXING CLUB.
I'M A TRAINER.
YOU GUYS GOTTA HAVE THAT HUNGER.
YOU EVER HEAR OF
A HUNGRY FIGHTER?
I WANT YOU GUYS TO BE
HUNGRY FIGHTERS 'CAUSE YOU'RE
FIGHTING FOR THE COMPETITION.
SO WE'RE GONNA DO THIS.
WE'RE GONNA GET YOU GUYS
INTO GREAT SHAPE.
Jenascia: I NEVER WORK OUT.
Martin: YOU'RE IN
A COMPETITION WITH SOMEBODY.
YOU'RE FIGHTING SOMEBODY.
EVERY DAY YOU WAKE UP
OUT OF BED, YOU'RE
FIGHTING SOMETHING, RIGHT?
YOU GOTTA FIGURE IT OUT,
OVERCOME IT, ALL RIGHT?
Yoanna: I'M LEARNING
ABOUT COMPETITION
AND THAT YOU CAN WIN,
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO IT
IN A MEAN OR AGGRESSIVE WAY.
Martin: JAB, PUSH, JAB, PUSH.
JAB, PUSH, JAB, PUSH.
Camille: IT IS
A COMPETITION, AND CAN'T LET
THE WEAKNESS GET TO YOU.
Martin: ALL RIGHT,
I'M GONNA WEIGH YOU GUYS.
TANYA'S GONNA MEASURE YOU.
Tanya: AND 36.
Martin: 36.
124. WHEW! BEAT IT.
Camille: THIS DOES NOT SAY
124.
124 IS RIGHT THERE.
Martin: HOLD ON.
TAKE A STEP BACK.
(whistles) ZIP IT.
Yoanna: I'D ALWAYS WANTED
TO MODEL, BUT MY BODY
WASN'T IN THE FORM TO MODEL.
Martin: YOANNA.
COME ON, KID.
Yoanna: I WAS
A LITTLE NERVOUS WEIGHING IN.
I LOST SOME WEIGHT
BEFORE I CAME.
IT WAS ABOUT 45 POUNDS I'VE LOST
IN ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF.
Martin: HIPS.
Tanya: 35 1/2.
Camille: YOANNA IS VERY
CONSCIOUS OF, LIKE, HER IMAGE.
THE ISSUE WITH HER
LOSING ALL THIS WEIGHT,
LIKE SHE WASN'T SECURE
WITHIN HER OWN SKIN.
Martin: BEAT IT.
AH! DUH-DUH-DUH-DUH!
138. GIVE AN EXTRA POUND
FOR CHEATING.
Tanya: SHANDI?
30.
Martin: HOW MUCH
IS THE WAIST?
Tanya: 25 1/2.
Catie: I THOUGHT
I WAS INCREDIBLY THIN
UNTIL I SAW SHANDI.
Martin: 106.
YOU GOTTA BE 36, BETHANY.
Bethany: I THINK THERE'S
GONNA BE SOME ISSUES
WITH MY BOOBS.
Tanya: 33 1/2.
April: THERE'S NO WAY
SHE'S 33.
I'M 33.
Bethany: PEOPLE ARE LIKE,
"YOU ARE NOT 34
AROUND YOUR BOOBS."
I'M JUST LIKE,
"SHUT THE HELL UP."
I'M BLONDE AND HAVE, I GUESS,
BIGGER BOOBS THAN
THE REST OF THEM.
PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND
THAT I AM OKAY WITH IT,
BUT THEY'RE NOT.
♪♪♪
Jenascia: THIS IS THE SPOT.
Mercedes: WE GO
TO THIS PLACE CALLED THE SHOW
WHERE WE MEET J. ALEXANDER,
AND HE TEACHES US HOW TO WALK.
Women: WHOO!
♪♪♪
Xiomara: J. ALEXANDER
WAS WAITING FOR US
IN THIS REALLY STRANGE
WOMAN'S BODY T-SHIRT.
J.: WELL, SURPRISE,
SURPRISE, SURPRISE.
WELCOME, WELCOME, WELCOME,
WELCOME, WELCOME.
GATHER 'ROUND, GATHER 'ROUND,
GATHER 'ROUND.
Yoanna: I LOVE J.
HE HAS TAUGHT SOME
OF THE BEST GIRLS,
LIKE, IN THIS INDUSTRY.
J.: TODAY WHAT I'M GONNA DO
IS I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
A FEW HINTS ON HOW TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
LET ME SHOW YOU
HOW A REAL MODEL WALKS.
MAGGIE RIZER.
♪♪♪
Xiomara: OH, MY GOD.
MAGGIE RIZER WALKED
DOWN THE RUNWAY.
Sara: I'M LIKE, THIS IS REAL.
LIKE, WE ARE MEETING,
LIKE SUPERMODELS RIGHT NOW.
J.: VOILà.
WELCOME, MAGGIE. MAGGIE RIZER.
Yoanna: I THINK WHAT
IMPRESSED ME MOST ABOUT MAGGIE
IS THAT SHE LOOKED LIKE
SHE HAD A HEALTHY PHYSIQUE
AND THAT SHE WASN'T RAIL-THIN.
AND IT JUST SHOWS YOU THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE
A SIZE NEGATIVE 0
TO MAKE IT IN THIS INDUSTRY.
J.: OKAY, SO I'M GONNA
HAVE YOU WALK, ONE BY ONE.
Shandi: I AM COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT FROM EVERYONE ELSE.
I DON'T EVEN, LIKE,
OWN A PAIR OF HIGH HEELS.
J.: HELP.
MISS SHANDI--SHE'S ALWAYS
LOOKING AT HER FEET AS THOUGH
HER FEET ARE GOING TO GUIDE HER,
AND THEY'RE ONLY
GONNA TRIP HER UP.
J.: AH! AH!
GET UP. KEEP ON WALKING, BABY.
Heather: I THINK IT SHOWS
EVERYONE THIS IS OBVIOUSLY
NOT VERY EASY TO WALK IN.
J.: JUST GIVE HER
SOME MORE LENGTH.
OOH, CHILD!
Jenascia: I'M NOT SHORT.
I REFUSE.
I ABSOLUTELY REFUSE
TO WALK AROUND IN HEELS
FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE.
I DO, HOWEVER,
WISH I WAS TALLER.
J.: JENASCIA, YOU SHOULD
WALK THE GOWN AND NOT HAVE
THE GOWN WALK YOU.
XIOMARA, WALK A LITTLE BIT
FASTER.
I NEED A LITTLE MORE OF A STRUT.
MERCEDES NEEDS TO MAKE IT
LESS MODELING SCHOOL
AND A LITTLE MORE CURRENT.
Xiomara: BETHANY'S BODY
IS MORE VOLUPTUOUS.
Bethany: WELL, OBVIOUSLY,
I KNOW THAT I DON'T HAVE
A STICK-THIN FIGURE,
BUT QUITE HONESTLY,
NEITHER DOES HALF OF AMERICA.
J.: APRIL, AS I SEE HER NOW,
IT'S ALMOST THIS FUNNY SLIDE,
VERY TIMID WAY OF WALKING,
ALMOST LIKE
SHE'S TOO EMBARRASSED.
SHAKE. SHAKE YOUR BODY.
THIS GIRL CATIE, I THINK,
MAYBE SHE COULD BE A MODEL.
I SEE SOMETHING NATURALLY
THAT KIND OF WORKS FOR HER.
SARA--OPENING UP HER MOUTH.
SHE'S LIKE A FISH.
OH, HERE SHE COMES.
MISS BLING-BLING.
MISS CAMILLE.
I THINK HER WALK,
WITH A FEW ADJUSTMENTS,
SHE'LL BE GREAT.
OH, SEE, I...
SEE, YOU KNOW, BLACK GIRLS
ALWAYS HAVE TO GIVE THAT EXTRA.
I AIN'T MAD AT YOU.
Yoanna: CAMILLE PUTS ON
A SHOW, AND I THINK
EVERYONE RECOGNIZES THAT.
Camille: I'M JUST FOCUSED
AND DETERMINED
ON WHAT I WANNA DO.
MAYBE YOANNA DIDN'T LIKE THAT
ABOUT ME AND MAYBE WISHED THAT
SHE COULD BE MORE COMFORTABLE
IN HER SKIN AS I AM IN MINE.
J.: WHOO!
WE GONNA HAVE FUN.
WE ARE GONNA HAVE FUN.
MISS YOANNA,
YOUR WALK REALLY IS AS USELESS
AS A FLASHLIGHT
WITH NO BATTERIES IN THE DARK.
(laughter)
J.: YOANNA, I NEED YOU
TO RELAX THROUGH HERE.
I DON'T WANT YOU TO DO...
(imitating horse whinnying)
(laughter)
J.: NO, WE CAN'T HAVE THAT.
SO I'LL SEE YOU GUYS
AFTER LUNCH, OKAY?
Yoanna: I'M ONE
OF THOSE PEOPLE--
IF SOMEONE HAS AN ISSUE
OR MIGHT BE SAYING SOMETHING
ABOUT ME, COME TO ME AND SAY IT,
YOU KNOW?
Yoanna: DON'T START.
Camille: WHAT ARE YOU
HEARING?
Yoanna: DON'T START, CAMILLE.
IT'S SO OLD, IT'S SO OLD.
Camille: WHAT ARE YOU
HEARING?
Yoanna: YOUR ATTITUDE.
Camille: IF I HAVE SOMETHING
TO SAY TO YOU,
I WILL SAY IT TO YOUR FACE.
Yoanna: THE LAST COUPLE TIMES
YOU'VE HAD THINGS TO SAY
ABOUT ME, YOU'VE NEVER SAID IT
TO MY FACE,
AND WHEN I
CONFRONTED YOU ABOUT IT--
Camille: I HAVEN'T SAID ANYTHING
TO YOU--
Yoanna: OKAY, OKAY, ENJOY.
THANK YOU.
Sara: I THINK WHAT'S GOING ON
RIGHT NOW WITH THE WHOLE
CAMILLE/YOANNA SHE SAID,
SHE SAID KINDA STUFF--
IT'S JUST THAT.
IT'S JUST HIGH SCHOOL STUFF.
Camille: AND TRUST ME, IF I
HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY TO YOU,
I WILL SAY IT TO YOUR FACE.
Yoanna: I DON'T TRUST YOU.
I DO NOT TRUST YOU.
Camille: BUT THAT'S MY WORD.
Sara: WHOO!
Yoanna: IT'S SO HARD
TO DEAL WITH HER BECAUSE
I THINK SHE'S VERY NEGATIVE.
IT'S HARD TO, LIKE, ASSESS,
LIKE, WHAT'S SHE'S TRYING TO DO.
HONEY, OKAY, END OF DISCUSSION.
Camille: I THINK THAT YOANNA
LOOKS AT ME AND SHE SEES THAT
I'M VERY COMFORTABLE IN MY SKIN,
AND MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT SHE WISHED
THAT SHE POSSESSED
OR SHE'S TRYING TO GET THERE.
I'M JUST, YOU KNOW,
A GROWN-ASS WOMAN
THAT WANTS TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M HERE TO DO.
BUT I WILL NOT LET SOMEBODY,
YOU KNOW, DISRESPECT ME.
REALLY, LIKE, DON'T PLAY ME.
LIKE, YOU HAVE A BETTER CHANCE
AT PLAYING LOTTO, AND THAT'S
JUST, LIKE, ONE IN A BILLION.
♪♪♪
Jenascia: I'VE HEARD A LOT OF
(bleep) TALKING ABOUT CAMILLE,
AND I BELIEVE THAT THERE'S GONNA
BE A LOT OF DRAMA IN THE HOUSE.
Camille: FOR REAL, IF I HAVE
SOMETHING TO SAY TO YOU,
I WILL SAY IT TO YOUR FACE.
Yoanna: SO WHEN I
CONFRONTED YOU ABOUT IT--
Camille: I HAVEN'T SAID
ANYTHING TO YOU...
Catie: I LIKE
CAMILLE'S CONFIDENCE.
SHE'S NOT HERE TO MAKE
A BUNCH OF BEST FRIENDS,
BUT SHE'S HERE TO WIN THIS.
TYRA MAIL.
"YOU'VE LEARNED RUNWAY
FROM THE BEST.
NOW IT'S TIME TO PUT IT
TO THE TEST.
YOU'RE MEETING A TOP
NEW YORK DESIGNER TOMORROW.
BE READY BY 10 A.M."
♪ DUM, DUM, DUM ♪♪
Yoanna: TODAY I KNOW WE'RE GONNA
BE MEETING
A FASHION DESIGNER,
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHO
IT'S GOING TO BE
OR WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR.
Carmen: GOOD MORNING, LADIES.
Women: GOOD MORNING.
Carmen: WELL,
I'M CARMEN MARC VALVO,
AND WELCOME TO MY SHOWROOM.
Catie: WHEN I THINK
OF FASHION DESIGNERS,
I THINK OF WET SEAL AND GAP
AND EXPRESS.
Yoanna: CARMEN MARC VALVO
IS ONE OF NEW YORK'S
TOP FASHION DESIGNERS.
THERE'S SUCH QUALITY
AND DETAILING IN HIS WORK.
I'M SO EXCITED TO BE
IN HIS SHOWROOM.
Carmen: YESTERDAY
I UNDERSTAND THAT THEY
TAUGHT YOU HOW TO WALK,
OR THE FINER POINTS OF IT.
WELL, THIS MORNING WE'RE GOING
TO PUT THOSE POINTS TO THE TEST.
THE PERSON I FEEL HAS DONE
THE BEST GETS TO COME
TO MY HOME THIS EVENING.
I'M HAVING A COCKTAIL PARTY.
Sara: OH, MY GOD.
Carmen: THERE'LL BE
SOME WONDERFUL PEOPLE THERE--
SOME INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE
IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY.
SO LET'S GET STARTED, OKAY?
COME ON, FOLLOW ME.
Yoanna: OF COURSE
I WANNA BE IN HIS HOUSE
AND I WANNA GO AND MEET
ALL THE FASHION PEOPLE THAT WORK
WITH CARMEN MARC VALVO.
I DON'T KNOW.
SOMEONE THERE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO DISCOVER ME AT HIS HOUSE.
Carmen: SOME OF
MY CELEBRITY CLIENTELE INCLUDE
LUCY LIU, KIM CATTRALL,
VANESSA WILLIAMS,
JUST TO NAME A FEW.
THESE ARE THE EVENING GOWNS
THAT I HAVE SELECTED FOR YOU.
SOME OF THEM MAY BE
TOO LONG FOR YOU,
AND SOME MAY BE TOO SHORT.
THAT HAPPENS.
♪♪♪
Catie: I HAVE THIS PROBABLY
THOUSANDS OF DOLLAR DRESS ON.
IT'S CRAZY.
Yoanna: SO MANY THOUGHTS
ARE RUNNING THROUGH MY HEAD.
I'VE SEEN CARMEN MARC VALVO
ON TV, AND HERE I AM
GETTING READY TO WALK FOR HIM?
IT WAS UNBELIEVABLE.
Carmen: WAY TOO MUCH MAKEUP.
IF YOU WERE COMING IN
FOR A CASTING AND YOU LOOKED
THE WAY YOU LOOKED, I PROBABLY
WOULDN'T EVEN ASK YOU
TO PUT ON A DRESS.
USUALLY UGLY WOMEN
PUT ON A LOT OF MAKEUP.
COME WITH ME, LADIES.
YOUR JOB IS TO SELL THE DRESS.
YOUR JOB IS TO HAVE
A PHOTOGRAPHER
TAKE A PICTURE OF YOU.
OKAY? TAKE A WALK.
Mercedes: WALKING FOR CARMEN
WAS A BIG CHALLENGE,
BECAUSE HE WANTED ELEGANCE,
HE WANTED DOMINANCE
AT THE SAME TIME.
HE WANTED IT TO BE VERY SMOOTH.
Carmen: YOU DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH STRIDE.
CAREFUL OF YOUR RIGHT ARM.
IT'S LIKE A DEAD ARM.
Shandi: SINCE I'VE NEVER
DONE THIS BEFORE,
I'M REALLY UNSURE OF MYSELF,
AND I JUST NEED
TO GET OVER THAT.
Carmen: SHANDI--
SHE'S NOT COMFORTABLE
IN HER OWN SHOES.
SHE'S STILL VERY TIMID,
AND HER BODY LANGUAGE
IS VERY, VERY INTROVERTED,
AND SHE NEEDS TO OVERCOME THAT.
I THINK CAMILLE HAS
A PRETTY POWERFUL PRESENCE.
THAT'S ACTUALLY VERY GOOD.
JENASCIA, NOT SO HEAVY
ON THE FEET.
JUST GLIDE MORE.
YOUR TURN--YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU WERE DOING A DOUBLE AXEL
ON ICE SKATES OR SOMETHING.
DON'T BE AFRAID.
SEE, IT'S MOVING, ISN'T IT?
YOANNA, IN MY OPINION,
HAS TO BUILD UP
HER OWN SELF-CONFIDENCE
AND LEARN TO STAND
A LITTLE BIT STRAIGHTER.
♪♪♪
Carmen: VERY GOOD.
YOUR WALK WAS NICE.
YOUR ARMS WERE GOOD, TOO.
WALK IT SLOWLY. VERY GOOD.
COME BACK.
OKAY, BOTH SIDES.
(trilling)
LIKE A TWIRLING DERVISH.
Bethany: THE DRESS--
IT WAS SERIOUSLY
2 FEET TOO LONG.
EVERYBODY ELSE HAD
THESE DRESSES THAT FIT.
Carmen: JUST PRETEND IT'S
THE WAY IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE.
Bethany: OKAY.
Carmen: BETHANY LOOKED
REALLY GOOD.
SHE LOOKED BEAUTIFUL
IN THE GOWN.
SHE ACTUALLY CARRIED IT
WITH A LOT OF GRACE.
VERY, VERY GOOD. GREAT.
Bethany: I HOPE THAT PEOPLE
WOULD STOP LOOKING AT MY TITS
AND START LOOKING
AT SOME TALENT HERE.
Carmen: OKAY, LADIES, CAN I HAVE
YOUR ATTENTION, PLEASE?
SHANDI, YOU WERE REALLY,
VERY, VERY STIFF.
YOU KNOW, YOU WERE LIKE
THE SHRINKING VIOLET,
SO YOU NEED TO WORK ON THAT
A LITTLE BIT.
CATIE, RIGHT?
Catie: YEAH.
Carmen: VERY GRACEFUL.
Catie: THANK YOU.
Carmen: VERY NICE COMPOSURE
ON THE RUNWAY.
I MEAN, YOU CAME OUT,
AND I WENT... (gasps)
VERY, VERY NICE.
Catie: THANK YOU.
Carmen: YOANNA,
YOU'RE SO CONSCIOUS
OF WHAT YOUR BODY'S DOING.
IT'S LIKE YOU'RE NOT HAVING FUN
ON THE RUNWAY.
IT ALL HAS TO DO
WITH CONFIDENCE,
HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT YOURSELF,
AND PROJECTING THAT
EITHER IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA
OR ON THE RUNWAY.
CAMILLE, WHEN YOU WERE DOWN
DOING YOUR PHOTO OP,
YOU JUST MILKED THAT CAMERA
OVER AND OVER AGAIN
AND DID NOT WANT TO LEAVE.
Camille: BECAUSE
THE LAST RUNWAY SHOW THAT I DID,
THEY TOLD ME I DIDN'T SPEND
ENOUGH TIME AT THE END
OF THE RUNWAY.
Carmen: OHH.
YOUR WALK IS A LITTLE--
IT'S A LITTLE SPORTSWEAR.
SO YOU HAVE TO KEEP
YOUR COMPOSURE DOWN.
Camille: SOMEONE THAT
TRAINED US HOW TO WALK--
HE SAID WALK FAST.
Carmen: LISTEN TO WHAT
EVERYONE IS TELLING YOU...
Camille: AND FIND
YOUR OWN MEDIUM.
Carmen: OR TEACHES YOU,
AND YOU HAVE TO FIND
WHAT YOU'RE COMFORTABLE WITH.
CAMILLE WAS A LITTLE AGGRESSIVE
IN THE SHOWROOM.
SO I WAS LITTLE BIT...
(grunts)
Mercedes: CAMILLE WASN'T
ACCEPTING HER RESPONSIBILITIES
OF MESSING UP, YOU KNOW?
JUST SAY, "OKAY. THANK YOU."
Yoanna: I WAS JUST KIND OF
EMBARRASSED, BECAUSE WE WERE
GUESTS IN HIS SHOWROOM,
AND I THOUGHT IT WAS TACKY.
Carmen: IT WAS NOT, UM,
AN EASY DECISION FOR ME TO MAKE.
YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
SO I'M GOING TO PICK
WHOM I THINK DID THE BEST JOB,
AND IS GOING TO BE COMING
TO MY HOME THIS EVENING.
CATIE, COME ON OVER.
Yoanna: OHH!
Catie: THANK YOU.
Carmen: I DECIDED TO PICK
CATIE AS THE WINNER.
SHE WALKED WITH SUCH COMPOSURE
AND GRACE,
THAT SHE HAD ME CONVINCED
SHE BELONGED ON A RUNWAY.
TWO NAMES--
TWO FRIENDS RIGHT NOW.
THEY'RE COMING WITH YOU.
TWO NAMES. NOW. COME ON.
Catie: MERCEDES AND CAMILLE.
I ENJOY BOTH MERCEDES
AND CAMILLE,
AND THEY'RE MY ROOMMATES,
SO I THOUGHT, WHO BETTER?
Yoanna: I WASN'T TOO EXCITED
ABOUT HER CHOICE IN CAMILLE,
BECAUSE I THOUGHT CAMILLE WOULD
TRY AND STEAL THE THUNDER
FROM CATIE.
CAMILLE--SHE'S SUCKING
ALL OF OUR ENERGY OUT
SO WE CAN BE WEAK AND CONFUSED
AND NOT KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
JUST SO THAT WE CAN BE SO
(bleep) IN THE HEAD
THAT WHEN IT'S TIME TO PERFORM,
SHE'S MESSED WITH US.
AND SHE IS SO MANIPULATIVE
AND SO SNEAKY ABOUT IT.
Catie: I'VE BEEN COMPLETELY
OBLIVIOUS THAT YOU GUYS
DID NOT LIKE HER.
Bethany: ARE YOU SERIOUS? Catie:
YEAH.
Bethany: NOBODY HERE
LIKES HER.
Catie: I WANNA KNOW IF
THE STUFF THEY WERE SAYING
IS TRUE.
Yoanna: YOU WERE THE ONE--
HE LOVED THE WAY YOU WALKED.
HE SAW GRACE IN YOU.
YOU DON'T KNOW IF HE'S GONNA
BOOK YOU FOR THE NEXT SHOW.
DON'T LET MISS CRUELLA DE VIL
TAKE THAT AWAY FROM YOU.
Catie: IF CAMILLE IS
PICKING ON PEOPLE LIKE
THEY'RE TELLING ME,
THEN I'M VERY DISAPPOINTED,
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT THE PERSON
I THOUGHT SHE WAS.
Catie: IF I COULD
TAKE IT BACK, LIKE, IF I COULD
RECHOOSE PEOPLE, I WOULD.
I DON'T WANT HER USING ME.
Bethany: CAMILLE--SHE'S USING
EVERYBODY AND ANY MEANS
AND ANYTHING AROUND HER
TO GET WHAT SHE WANTS.
SHE'S PRETTY,
BUT HER ATTITUDE MAKES HER UGLY.
Yoanna: THE MORE
I GET TO SEE HER,
SHE GETS HIDEOUS.
LIKE, AAH!
♪♪♪
Mercedes: OH, IS THIS
FOR TONIGHT?
Catie: (screams)
Bethany: THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
GONNA WEAR TONIGHT.
Catie: "CATIE, CAMILLE
AND MERCEDES, YOU CAN'T GO TO
"A PARTY AT CARMEN MARC VALVO'S
HOUSE WITHOUT BEING DRESSED
"IN CARMEN MARC VALVO.
PLEASE ENJOY
THESE COCKTAIL DRESSES."
(gasps)
Mercedes: SO PRETTY!
Sara: THAT'S SO BEAUTIFUL.
Catie: I'VE NEVER HAD
ANYTHING SO PRETTY.
HEY, I'M KEEPING THIS,
IF THAT'S OKAY.
Sara: I THINK IT'S YOURS.
IT IS YOURS.
Catie: I WANNA KEEP
THAT LETTER.
Xiomara: YEAH, DEFINITELY.
Catie: SO NOW WHEN CAMILLE
DOES LITTLE THINGS,
I AM MORE AWARE OF IT.
Camille: CAN WE HAVE, LIKE,
A GROUP MEETING OR SOMETHING?
Mercedes: WE NEED ONE.
Camille: 'CAUSE THIS IS
JUST... RIDICULOUS.
Mercedes: YEAH, 'CAUSE WE
WERE ALL TALKING ABOUT IT.
Catie: HEY, GIRLS,
I THINK WE SHOULD ALL HAVE
A HOUSE MEETING AND JUST
NIP ALL THIS IN THE BUD
AND GET IT OUT THERE, BECAUSE...
Yoanna: LET'S GO.
HOUSE MEETING!
Catie: THAT'S WHY I THINK...
Camille: WHAT THE... IS
YOANNA SO... EXCITED ABOUT
A HOUSE MEETING?
Yoanna: I LOVE
HOUSE MEETINGS.
I THINK THEY BRING MORE...
Camille: I HAVE NO PROBLEM
GOING INTO THIS MEETING,
BECAUSE I HAVE NOTHING TO HIDE.
SO ONLY PERSON WITH THE HAND
IS THE PERSON
THAT'S ALLOWED TO TALK?
Catie: YEP.
PERSON WHO HAS THIS HAND
CAN TALK.
I'VE BEEN COMPLETELY OBLIVIOUS,
AND I JUST WANNA KNOW,
LIKE, WHAT'S UP,
WHAT I'VE BEEN MISSING,
WHAT I HAVEN'T BEEN NOTICING.
Camille: EVERYONE HAS
AN ISSUE WITH... MY CHARACTER,
MY PERSONALITY,
WHAT I HAVE DONE
AND WHAT I HAVEN'T DONE.
WE'RE GONNA CLARIFY ALL THAT
RIGHT NOW.
WHOEVER WANTS TO, UM,
START TALKING ABOUT CAMILLE,
GO AHEAD.
Bethany: HONESTLY,
ALL I HAVE TO SAY IS THAT
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU HAVE AN EXCUSE
FOR EVERYTHING.
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU CAN'T TAKE
THE BLAME FOR SOMETHING,
AND YOU KEEP SAYING THAT
EVERYONE KEEPS PERCEIVING YOU
THE WRONG WAY, BUT IT'S--
Camille: NO, THAT'S WHAT OTHER
PEOPLE HAVE TOLD ME.
Bethany: BUT IT SEEMS LIKE
IF THERE'S EIGHT PEOPLE HERE,
I THINK THAT'S YOU, AND I THINK
YOU NEED TO JUST ACCEPT THAT
THAT'S YOU AND DEAL WITH IT,
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THAT
THERE'S EIGHT PEOPLE THAT ARE
JUST PERCEIVING YOU
IN THE WRONG WAY.
Mercedes: WELL, THE THING IS
IS THAT, YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY'S
HAVING AN ISSUE, YOU KNOW,
WITH YOUR PERSONALITY,
AND WE CAN'T CHANGE THAT.
IT JUST FEELS LIKE YOU GO
FROM HOT TO COLD.
Yoanna: IT IS GETTING
TO THE POINT WHERE IT IS
SO NEGATIVE IN THIS HOUSE,
THE ENERGY IS DRIVING ME CRAZY.
IT'S LIKE WE HAVE TO OPEN
THE WINDOWS AND JUST--
I'M NOT FINISHED! JUST WAIT.
Camille: THAT'S WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT.
Yoanna: BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHY?
IT'S JUST SO BUILT UP.
I'M SORRY.
Camille: WHERE DOES THAT HATE
AND THE ANGER COME FROM?
I WANNA KNOW WHERE THAT ANGER
COMES FROM, BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE
THAT ANGER INSIDE OF ME
FOR ANYONE.
Catie: I MEAN, TO BE HONEST,
CAMILLE, THE REASON WHY
THIS WAS ALL ABOUT--
THEY WERE WORRIED THAT, LIKE,
BECAUSE I BROUGHT YOU,
THAT YOU WERE GONNA TRY
AND MAKE IT ALL ABOUT YOU,
WHEN REALLY--I MEAN,
THIS SOUNDS SELFISH,
BUT I'M THE ONE WHO WON,
AND I WANNA MAKE IT ABOUT ME.
Bethany: SHE WON THIS.
IT'S ALL ABOUT HER RIGHT NOW.
SHE BROUGHT YOU TWO
'CAUSE SHE TRUSTS YOU
AND SHE WANTS YOU THERE
WITH HER.
Camille: SO WHAT DO YOU THINK
I'M GONNA DO?
YOU THINK I'M GONNA GO THERE
AND, LIKE, PUSH HER INTO A BUNCH
OF CAVIAR OR SOMETHING?
Jenascia: THERE'S NO POINT
IN MAKING SMALL COMMENTS
AND SAYING MEAN THINGS
AND EGGING IT ON, 'CAUSE YOU'RE
JUST ASKIN' FOR A BIG FIGHT,
WHICH I HAVE TO LISTEN TO.
AND IT'S KILLIN' ME,
BECAUSE I AM SURFIN'
THE CRIMSON WAVES RIGHT NOW,
AND I JUST DON'T NEED THAT...
BECAUSE I HAVE MY OWN PROBLEMS,
YOU KNOW?
Camille: AND I'M GOING
TO THE PARTY BECAUSE SOMEBODY
CHOSE ME BECAUSE THEY
OBVIOUSLY LIKE ME.
I'M NOT TRIPPIN'. I'M COOL.
I'M JUST SAYING IT'S JUST GONNA
BE CAMILLE, DO MY THING.
Catie: AND PERSONALLY,
YOU'VE NEVER BEEN MEAN TO ME
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT, SO...
Camille: I DON'T THINK
I'VE BEEN MEAN TO ANYONE.
THE ONLY PERSON THAT I'VE GOT UP
IN THEIR FACE TO WAS YOANNA,
BECAUSE SHE CAME TO ME
AND ACCUSED ME OF SAYING
SEVERAL THINGS
WHICH I HAVE NEVER SAID.
I SAID, "IF I HAVE SOMETHING
TO SAY TO YOU,
I'LL SAY IT TO YOUR FACE,"
AND THAT WAS THAT.
OTHER THAN THAT, I'M SAYING
STAY... OUT OF MY WAY.
♪♪♪
Xiomara: I LIKE IT.
Catie: YAY!
Bethany: THAT'S SO GREAT.
Catie: I WON
THE WHOLE CONTEST WITH
CARMEN MARC VALVO.
I GOT TO INVITE TWO PEOPLE,
AND I INVITED MERCEDES
AND CAMILLE.
I WANT TO GO
TO HIS COCKTAIL PARTY SO BAD.
I WANNA HAVE THAT CONFIDENCE
TO KNOW THAT I'M THE BEST ONE
OUT OF THESE 11 GIRLS RIGHT NOW.
I'M SORRY.
Yoanna: NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
I UNDERSTAND.
Catie: I FEEL SO DEBUTANTE.
BYE, GIRLS!
Sara: YOANNA--
SHE'S KINDA CONCERNING ME.
SOMETHING'S NOT CLICKING,
BECAUSE SHE'S JUST PROBABLY
NOT 100%.
♪♪♪
Catie: SALUD.
Mercedes: SALUD.
Catie: OH, MY GOODNESS.
Mercedes: HI.
Carmen: WELCOME.
HEY.
AND CATIE, OUR WINNER.
LOOK HOW BEAUTIFUL YOU LOOK.
HI, CATIE. WELCOME.
SO WE TOOK CARE OF
SOME GOOD CLOTHES FOR YOU?
Catie: YEAH. VERY GOOD.
Mercedes: WE WOULD LOOK
SO CHEAP IF WE USED
OUR OWN CLOTHES.
Carmen: LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
THESE ARE MY FRIENDS,
AND THEY'RE THREE NEW, GREAT,
UP-AND-COMING MODELS.
Camille: IT WAS
INTERESTING TO KNOW.
Mercedes: CAMILLE IS REALLY,
REALLY GOOD AT NETWORKING.
I MEAN, REALLY GOOD.
Camille: I FELT COMPLETELY
HONORED.
I GOT AN OPPORTUNITY TO NETWORK
AND MEET OTHER PEOPLE
IN THE INDUSTRY.
Catie: THE VARIETY
IS WONDERFUL.
I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M HERE.
Camille: THANK YOU.
Carmen: I'VE DESIGNED A RING,
10 KARATS.
FLAWLESS.
YOU GET TO WEAR IT.
YOU CAN TAKE THAT ONE OFF, HON.
I THINK THIS IS YOUR SIZE.
Catie: I THINK
I CAN HANDLE THAT.
(laughter)
Carmen: THERE YOU GO.
ENJOY IT FOR THE EVENING.
CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU.
Catie: SEE YA.
(laughter)
♪♪♪
Xiomara: TYRA CAME OVER
TO SPEND TIME WITH US,
AND SHE WANTED TO SPEAK WITH US
ONE ON ONE INDIVIDUALLY.
Tyra: HOW YOU DOING
IN THE HOUSE?
HOW'S EVERYTHING GOING?
Shandi: THE ONLY THING THAT
I'VE BEEN HAVING A PROBLEM WITH
IS MY WALK.
Tyra: REMEMBER I SAID
MY FIRST FASHION SHOW
I WAS LIKE...
THINKING I WAS GREAT.
I WAS CONFIDENT
AND LOOKED LIKE A DAMN FOOL.
THAT CONFIDENCE GOT ME
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
Bethany: I WANT SOMETHING
TO WORK ON.
I CAN'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT MY CHEST.
Tyra: YES, YOU CAN.
YOU CAN POSE DIFFERENTLY.
YOU'RE NOT THE ONLY MODEL
THAT HAS A BIG CHEST.
THIS IS THIS INDUSTRY,
WHERE IT IS GONNA TALK ABOUT YOU
FROM YOUR HEAD TO YOUR TOES.
EVERY MODEL WHOSE CHEST
IS LIKE YOURS DOES NOT LOOK
LIKE YOUR PICTURE THE OTHER DAY.
Bethany: IF Y'ALL CAN'T STOP
LOOKING AT MY TITS
AND START LOOKING AT THE TALENT,
IT'S LIKE, I'M NOT GONNA
SIT HERE AND BE CRITICIZED
OF THE SAME THING.
Tyra: YOU'RE HERE BECAUSE
YOU WANNA BE A FASHION MODEL.
Bethany: WHAT CAN I DO?
BUT IT'S JUST--
Tyra: YOU'RE HERE.
SO YOU HAVE TO LEARN TO WORK
IN THIS WORLD.
Camille: YOANNA HAS JUST COME
TO ME AT SEVERAL POINT IN TIMES
AND ACCUSED ME
OF SAYING THINGS ABOUT HER
IN FRONT OF THE GROUP,
AND SO BECAUSE SHE'S MISTAKEN,
OTHER PEOPLE ARE TAKING IT
LIKE, YOU KNOW, I'M TWO-FACED,
AND THAT'S SO NOT THE CASE.
I'M SORRY IF...
I'M KIND OF, LIKE, AGGRESSIVE.
I KNOW WHAT I WANT RIGHT NOW
IN MY LIFE,
AND MY FOCUS IS DIFFERENT.
IT'S NOW OR NEVER.
Yoanna: THE GENERAL THING IS
IT'S HARD GETTING ALONG
WITH CAMILLE.
Tyra: IT'S HARD GETTING ALONG
WITH CAMILLE?
Yoanna: MM-HMM. SHE LIES,
AND I'VE CONFRONTED HER,
LIKE MAYBE IF I HEAR SOMETHING,
AND MAYBE I WAS JUST HEARING IT.
I EVEN PULLED HER ASIDE,
YOU KNOW, "DID YOU SAY THAT?"
THAT WAY, I DON'T GO AROUND
TO OTHER GIRLS
AND START SPREADING THINGS.
Tyra: DO YOU THINK SHE HAS
A PERSONAL PROBLEM WITH YOU,
OR...
Yoanna: I DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE, MAYBE. I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK IT'S COLLECTED ENERGY
AROUND THE HOUSE.
Tyra: YOU'RE WILLING TO STICK
THE WHOLE THING OUT?
Yoanna: MM-HMM, YEAH. HOPEFULLY,
YEAH.
Tyra: DO YOU WANNA WIN?
Yoanna: OH, YES.
Tyra: YES?
Yoanna: VERY BAD.
♪♪♪
Shandi: THIS MORNING
WE FIND OUT THAT THE PHOTO SHOOT
THAT WE WERE DOING TODAY--
WE HAVE TO BRING EVERYTHING
OURSELVES.
WE HAVE TO BRING OUTFITS
AND MAKEUP.
Tyra: HELLO, EVERYBODY.
Jay: HEY.
Mercedes: HI.
Tyra: WHAT'S UP, EVERYBODY?
AS YOU GUYS CAN SEE,
I'M STANDING HERE NEXT
TO A LOVELY MAN
WITH GORGEOUS BLOND HAIR,
AND IT'S COMING FROM HIS ROOTS.
IT'S SO NATURAL.
Jay: IT'S NATURAL, VERY.
Tyra: IT'S JUST AS NATURAL
AS MY RED HAIR IS.
BUT ANYWAY, THIS IS JAY MANUEL.
JAY IS MY PERSONAL MAKEUP ARTIST
FOR YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS.
THERE IS NOTHING
THIS MAN CANNOT DO.
Jenascia: THIS GUY IS PRETTY,
ALMOST PRETTIER THAN ME,
AND THAT'S A DAMN SHAME.
Tyra: HE IS SO TALENTED.
HE DOESN'T JUST DO MAKEUP.
HE DOES A LOT MORE,
AND HE'S GONNA EXPLAIN THAT
RIGHT NOW.
Jay: OKAY.
I'M GONNA BE YOUR ART DIRECTOR
FOR ALL YOUR PHOTO SHOOTS.
TODAY'S SHOOT, I DON'T HAVE
A HAIRDRESSER FOR YOU,
A MAKEUP ARTIST FOR YOU
OR A STYLIST FOR YOU.
YOU GUYS ARE GONNA CREATE
YOUR OWN IMAGES.
IT'S REALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR A TOP MODEL TO CONNECT
WITH HER OWN PERSONAL STYLE,
RIGHT, TYRA?
Tyra: YEAH, AND THIS IS
THE FIRST STEP TOWARDS
DOING THAT TODAY.
SO, YOU GUYS, HAVE FUN TODAY.
Women: THANK YOU. BYE!
Tyra: BYE.
Jay: TODAY'S SHOOT
YOU'RE GONNA BE WEARING
STEVE MADDEN SHOES,
BUT IF YOU TAKE A LOOK
OVER THERE AGAINST THE WINDOW,
THERE ARE ALL THESE SHOES
LINED UP.
YOU ALL HAVE TO CHOOSE
A PAIR OF SHOES,
AND THEN ONE BY ONE,
EACH OF YOU WILL GET
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME UP
TO DO YOUR HAIR, MAKEUP
AND GET YOURSELVES DRESSED.
THEN WHEN YOU'RE FINISHED THERE,
YOU SIT AND SELECT
FROM ALL YOUR PHOTOGRAPHS.
YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER TODAY--
HER NAME IS CHE GRAHAM.
YOU GUYS ARE IN COMPLETE CONTROL
OF YOUR IMAGE.
Shandi: THIS IS MY CHANCE
TO SHINE.
LIKE, I'M GONNA DO THIS
ON MY OWN.
Jay: ALL RIGHT, GO.
Bethany: OH, THESE LOOK
SO CUTE.
IT WAS A MAD RUSH TO THE SHOES,
AND OF COURSE,
CAMILLE WAS
THE FIRST ONE OVER THERE.
SHE HAD, LIKE, THREE PAIR
OF BOOTS IN HER HAND
WHILE EVERYBODY ELSE
IS TRYING TO FIND SHOES.
Jay: MERCEDES?
Mercedes: YES?
Jay: YOU ARE FIRST.
Mercedes: ALL RIGHT.
THE JUDGES ARE REALLY LOOKING
FOR THAT SHOE.
LIKE, ARE YOU PUTTING
THE SHOE OUT THERE?
SO I HAD AN ORANGE SCARF
AND I HAD ORANGE SHOES,
SO I WAS KINDA GOING
FOR THAT TOUGH, CUTE LOOK.
Jay: WE'RE GONNA
WALK YOU OVER.
♪♪♪
Ché: GOOD, GOOD. GOOD,
THAT'S GOOD.
Jay: HEATHER IS GONNA
COME UP ON SET.
MERCEDES, COME WITH ME.
WE'RE GONNA GO BACK HERE.
SO IN A FEW MINUTES,
YOUR PICTURES ARE GONNA APPEAR
UP ON THE SCREEN,
AND YOU JUST MAKE YOUR SELECTS.
Mercedes: SO WEIRD.
SO MUCH PRESSURE.
I LIKE THAT.
Ché: THAT'S IT.
Jay: THAT'S IT.
Xiomara: (laughing)
CAMILLE...
WAS TRYING
TO DO MOVEMENT SHOTS.
SHE'S, LIKE, FALLING
ALL OVER THE PLACE
AND MAKING THIS LOUD NOISE.
IT WAS, LIKE, TEN OTHER PEOPLE
SITTING THERE WATCHING ME,
WHICH IS COOL,
BECAUSE I'M CONFIDENT.
I DON'T MIND WHEN PEOPLE
STARE AT ME.
IT'S A COMPETITION.
I'M HERE TO WIN--
I'M GONNA DO MY BEST.
Yoanna: I WANNA PROVE
THAT I CAN BE CONFIDENT
AND NOT SO NERVOUS
AND THAT I CAN DO ON CUE
WHATEVER ANYONE NEEDS ME TO DO.
Jay: YOANNA?
Ché: YEAH. COOL.
Yoanna: I JUST TRIED
TO FIGURE IT OUT,
LIKE BE AWARE OF THE SHOE,
BE AWARE THAT I'M NOT
OVERDOING IT,
LIKE, WITH MY FACE.
Ché: BEAUTIFUL.
Jay: YOANNA KNOWS
HOW TO MOVE.
YOANNA'S BONE STRUCTURE IS--
Ché: BONE STRUCTURE--BEYOND.
Jay: BEAUTIFUL.
Ché: OH, YEAH.
OH, MY GOD. THAT'S GREAT!
Jenascia: CAN EVERYONE
JUST TURN AROUND?
Ché: YEAH.
Jenascia: I LOOK... GRR!
THE HAIR'S OUT OF CONTROL HERE.
Ché: OH, YEAH.
WOW.
Catie: OH!
Ché: GORGEOUS.
WHOO! DAMN GOOD.
WOW. THAT'S GOOD.
Xiomara: THANK YOU.
Ché: YEAH, GREAT. GREAT.
Jay: YOU READY?
April: YEAH.
Ché: YES. OH, I LIKE THAT.
Shandi: I HAVE NEVER WORN
BOOTS LIKE THIS.
IT MADE ME WANNA WORK IT,
LIKE JUST GET ALL FUNKY
AND CRAZY.
Jay: I THINK SHANDI COULD
DEFINITELY BENEFIT
FROM A MAKEUP LESSON.
Ché: IT'S GOOD. YEP. WOW.
GREAT.
Bethany: SO HARD TO SEE
THE FRONT OF THESE SHOES.
Ché: OH, THESE ARE CUTE.
THAT'S IT. WE'RE DONE.
Bethany: OKAY.
TYRA SAID BE CAREFUL ABOUT
POKING MY CHEST OUT,
AND IT'S ABOUT THE SHOES.
IT'S NOT REALLY ABOUT ME,
I GUESS.
Jay: YOU GOTTA
GIVE IT TO ME NOW.
Bethany: 55...
NO, 94, 94.
Jay: SO THAT'S YOUR PICTURE.
THAT'S THE ONE YOU SELECTED.
WE'RE DONE.
Xiomara: TYRA MAIL!
I NEVER READ THIS.
I NEVER READ THEM,
SO I'M GONNA READ IT.
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY TEN OF YOU WILL CONTINUE ON
WITH THE HOPE OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED."
WE HAVE TO EXCHANGE
PHONE NUMBERS, YOU GUYS.
Yoanna: I REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHO'S GONNA BE ELIMINATED,
JUST BECAUSE I'M SO FOCUSED
ON WANTING TO WIN THIS,
AND I WANNA WIN IT SO BAD.
Xiomara: ELIMINATION
TOMORROW.
Yoanna: I'VE NEVER HAD AS MUCH
CONFRONTATION
WITH A FEMALE IN MY WHOLE LIFE
AS I HAVE HAD WITH CAMILLE.
I'M NOT GONNA LET CAMILLE WIN.
TO ME, THAT'S WHAT'S KEEPING ME
IN THIS COMPETITION.
Sara: SO DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA
WHO YOU THINK MIGHT BE
ON THE BLOCK TODAY?
Catie: PERSONALLY,
I REALLY DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE GOING ON.
Bethany: I'M NERVOUS NOW,
ESPECIALLY TONIGHT
BEING ELIMINATION--
I'M VERY NERVOUS.
Jenascia: I'VE HEARD
A FEW TIMES, YOU KNOW,
"YOU'RE SHORT. YOU'RE SHORT.
LOOK TALLER."
SCREW IT.
I'M GONNA BE SHORT,
AND YOU GUYS ARE GONNA LIKE IT.
Shandi's boyfriend: I hope
you get eliminated
so you can come home.
Shandi: DON'T SAY THAT, JERK.
IT'S TOO EARLY TO GO.
I STILL GOT A LOT OF GAME
TO PLAY.
♪♪♪
Tyra: HI, YOU GUYS.
Women: HI.
Tyra: HI.
IT'S TIME TO MAKE OUR SECOND CUT
TOWARDS DETERMINING WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE WINNER WILL RECEIVE
A CONTRACT WITH IMG,
WHICH IS THE NUMBER ONE
MODELING MANAGEMENT FIRM
IN THE WORLD
AND A SPREAD IN "JANE" MAGAZINE
AND A COSMETICS CAMPAIGN
WITH SEPHORA.
AND WE HAVE OUR JUDGES.
FIRST, WE HAVE
MISS JANICE DICKINSON,
ONE OF THE FIRST SUPERMODELS
OF THE WORLD.
ERIC NICHOLSON IS
THE SENIOR FASHION EDITOR
OF "JANE" MAGAZINE.
WE HAVE NIGEL BARKER,
WHO IS A TOP NOTED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
AND OF COURSE,
IN THE LITTLE NEWSBOY CAP
IS J. ALEXANDER, WORKIN' IT.
AND HE IS OUR SPECIAL
GUEST JUDGE THIS WEEK.
WE'RE GONNA BRING YOU IN
FOR YOUR EVALUATION,
AND AFTER THAT, WE'LL DETERMINE
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED.
J.: BUT FIRST, I WAS JUST
THINKING MAYBE WE SHOULD
GIVE YOU EACH A SLIP DRESS
AND A PAIR OF HIGH HEELS,
AND THEN YOU COME BACK
FOR SLAUGHTER.
Tyra: SO GO.
♪♪♪
Eric: BETTER THAN I THOUGHT.
J.: CAN I HAVE A STRONG, SEXY,
CONFIDENT WALK, PLEASE?
Janice: IT LOOKED TO ME THAT
YOU HADN'T PRACTICED AT ALL.
Tyra: YEAH, I THOUGHT
YOUR WALK WAS TOO FAST.
THIS IS YOUR ONE TIME,
YOU KNOW, TO REALLY SHOW US
WHAT YOU GOT,
SO YOU NEED TO MILK IT.
SO THEN YOU HAD
YOUR SELF-MADE PHOTO SHOOT,
WHERE YOU WERE ASKED TO DO
YOUR HAIR, YOUR MAKEUP,
YOUR STYLING
AND CHOOSE YOUR OWN PICTURE.
LUX IMAGING, THE PHOTO PRODUCERS
OF THE SHOOT
CHOSE THE VERY BEST PHOTOS,
AND THEN CREATED THE ADS.
AND BETHANY, IN YOUR CASE,
THIS WAS YOUR BEST PICTURE.
Janice: SHE'S DOING
A JANICE DICKINSON CIRCA 1978.
Nigel: I THINK THE PROBLEM IS
IS THAT YOU'RE NOT REALLY
DOING IT ENOUGH.
Tyra: YEAH, IF YOU WOULD'VE
ARCHED YOUR BACK,
PUSHED YOUR BOOTY
UP IN THE AIR...
J.: I WAS GONNA ACTUALLY
GET UP AND DO IT.
Tyra: WHY DON'T YOU?
WORK IT OUT. WORK IT OUT.
PUSH THE BOOTY OUT.
J.: YOU KNOW, JUST STAND UP, BUT
I CAN'T ARCH THE BOOTY.
Tyra: THERE YOU GO.
THERE'S THE BOOTY.
J.: EXTEND THE LEG OUT A BIT.
Tyra: JANICE IS DOING IT.
THAT'S WHAT YOU NEEDED TO DO.
J.: SHANDI, WHAT HAPPENED?
WHAT HAPPENED TO YOUR LEFT--
MY LEFT FOOT?
Janice: YOU NEED TO PRACTICE,
PRACTICE, PRACTICE.
EAT, SLEEP AND... IN YOUR HEELS
IF YOU HAVE TO.
I DON'T CARE.
WALK, WALK, WALK, WALK, WALK.
Eric: I LIKE THE POSE.
Nigel: I LIKE EVERYTHING
OTHER THAN THE FACE.
I THINK YOU'VE GOT
A MUCH BETTER FACE THAN THIS,
AND I'VE SEEN IT.
Tyra: SHANDI, YOU HAD
SO MANY BETTER PICTURES
THAN THIS.
WOW.
Janice: THIS IS
HEAVEN ON EARTH.
Tyra: THANKS, SHANDI.
Janice: APRIL IN PARIS.
THE POSEY WOSEY
AT THE END OF THE RUNWAY
REALLY REPULSED ME.
I'M SORRY.
J.: FOR ME, IT WAS JUST
A MATTER OF YOU CLEANING UP
THE END, BECAUSE YOU GET
COMPLETELY LOST.
Tyra: I LOVE THAT YOU HAVE
THE SHOE--LIKE, BAM.
THIS IS WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT,
BUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT YOUR FACE
THAT THE PUBLIC
REALLY WANTS TO SEE.
HERE'S YOUR PHOTO AS AN AD.
Janice: NICE.
J.: HEATHER,
YOU LEAD WITH YOUR CHIN,
AND WHEN YOU LEAD WITH YOUR CHIN
YOU ALSO TIGHTEN YOUR MOUTH.
Eric: I KNOW--I THINK
YOU WERE GOING FOR A SEXY,
SORT OF SULTRY EXPRESSION,
BUT IT COMES OFF A LITTLE BIT
LIKE YOU'RE SITTING
ON THE TOILET.
Tyra: SARA,
IT WAS WAY TOO MUCH JIGGLE.
J.: ALL THE FLIRTING.
DON'T GIVE HER A RUNWAY.
GIVE HER A CHAIR
AND A GOLD POLE.
Tyra: THIS IS THE PHOTO
THAT YOU CHOSE.
THAT'S HOT.
THAT'S ONE
OF THE BEST ONES I'VE SEEN.
AND HERE'S YOUR CHOICE AS AN AD.
Eric: BROOKE SHIELDS
CALVIN KLEIN AD, 1980.
Janice: NICE.
Tyra: I THINK YOUR WALK
WAS ABSOLUTELY FABULOUS.
YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOREVER.
Nigel: THE ARM
LOOKS VERY AWKWARD.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE ABOUT
TO FALL BACKWARDS, DOESN'T IT?
AND ALSO, A LONGER NECK.
THE PROPORTION MAKES
YOUR HEAD LOOK SMALL
AND YOUR WAIST LOOK LARGE.
Tyra: MERCEDES,
HERE'S YOUR CHOICE AS AN AD.
Eric: THIS SHOULD HAVE BEEN
COMPLETELY IN PROFILE,
AND IT WOULD BE GENIUS.
J.: I DIDN'T THINK
YOUR WALK WAS SEXY ENOUGH.
YOU ALMOST WALK
LIKE A LINEBACKER.
Janice: ARE YOU KIDDING ME
WITH THAT WALK?
HOW TALL ARE YOU, ANYWAY?
Jenascia: 5'7".
Janice: SEE, FOR 5'7",
YOU HAVE TO THINK TALL,
BECAUSE IF YOU THINK TALL,
YOU WILL BE TALL,
SO JUST TRY A LITTLE BIT HARDER.
Tyra: NOW, JENASCIA,
YOU CHOSE THIS PHOTO,
BUT THIS ONE WOULD HAVE
MADE AN ADVERTISER MUCH HAPPIER.
Eric: I SEE LIKE
A LITTLE KATE MOSS ALSO IN THIS.
J.: GIRL, YOU WALK
LIKE YOU ARE ON CRACK.
YOUR EYES ARE
SO BUGGED OUT OF YOUR HEAD,
LIKE SOMETHING JUST SCARED
THE HELL OUT OF YOU.
Nigel: XIOMARA, YOU DID LOOK
LIKE YOU WERE POSSESSED.
Janice: I DIG IT.
Nigel: YOUR BODY LOOKS GREAT,
VERY LONG, SLIM, TALL.
Eric: I LIKE THE SLITHER
SELLING THE SHOES.
Tyra: I THINK YOU HAVE
ONE OF THE STRONGEST WALKS
OF THE GIRLS,
BUT NOW YOU'VE GOT
TO THROW CATIE INTO IT.
J.: OOH,
YOU LOOK LIKE A PRETZEL.
Tyra: THIS LOOKS LIKE
YOU IN THE MALL, GIRL,
AND YOU WERE WALKING BY,
LIKE, THE PHOTO BOOTH PLACE.
AND THEY WERE LIKE,
"COME ON, TAKE PICTURES.
THEY'RE $5.99.
COME ON, YOU WANT
TO TAKE A PICTURE?"
AND YOU WERE LIKE, "YEAH!"
CATIE, OF ALL THE PHOTOS
YOU TOOK,
THIS ONE WAS ACTUALLY THE BEST.
J.: FLOAT LIKE A BUTTERFLY,
STING LIKE A ...DAMN BEE.
Eric: ALL THE GIRLS
WHO ARE OUT THERE
SHOULD WATCH OUT FOR YOU,
BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
Tyra: YOU'RE A SHOWGIRL.
YOU TOTALLY GET IT.
I'M A SHOWGIRL.
I'M A DRAG QUEEN
IN A WOMAN'S BODY,
AND I FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE
A LITTLE DRAG QUEEN IN YOU, TOO.
AND THIS IS THE PICTURE
THAT YOU CHOSE.
Janice: YEAH,
YOU REALLY UTILIZED
YOUR LONG, GORGEOUS SPIDER LEGS.
Tyra: CAMILLE,
HERE'S YOUR AD.
THAT LOOKS REALLY GREAT.
Yoanna: DON'T LOOK.
Tyra: YOUR WALK WAS A-PLUS.
J.: I GIVE YOU MAJOR POINTS
FOR THAT ONE.
Tyra: I FELT LIKE
I WAS IN A REAL FASHION SHOW
IN FASHION WEEK WATCHING A MODEL
THAT'S BEEN DOING THIS
FOR TEN YEARS.
Janice: THE SHOE
LOOKS A LITTLE BIG.
Nigel: IT LACKS
A LOT OF SEX APPEAL AND REALLY,
I WOULDN'T LOOK AT IT TWICE.
Tyra: YOANNA,
YOUR CHOICE WAS KIND OF AVERAGE.
WOW!
Eric: I LIKE THIS ONE
SO MUCH BETTER.
Tyra: THAT'S AN AD! I WOULD
BUY THOSE SHOES.
OKAY, THANK YOU.
MERCEDES.
Janice: MERCEDES, FOR ME,
JUST IS THE EPITOME OF A MODèLE.
Tyra: NEXT IS YOANNA.
Eric: SHE'S THE CLUMPER,
BUT SHE HAS A GREAT ATTITUDE.
Janice: I'M ON THE FENCE
WITH YOANNA.
Tyra: SHANDI.
Nigel: SHANDI
WAS IN SHAMBLES.
I DON'T KNOW. THE WALK TODAY
WAS JUST DREADFUL.
Eric: I'M HOPING THAT
SHE'S LIKE THIS LITTLE SEED
THAT WE'RE GOING TO FERTILIZE,
AND SHE'S GONNA BLOSSOM.
Tyra: APRIL.
Eric: SHE'S AMAZING.
Nigel: APRIL'S BODY IS,
I THINK, INCREDIBLE.
Tyra: CATIE.
Janice: HER FACE
IS A BIT PINCHED.
Tyra: JENASCIA.
Nigel: SHE REALLY DOESN'T
HAVE WHAT IT TAKES.
Janice: JENASCIA
IS TOO SHORT.
Eric: WITH JENASCIA
I DON'T THINK IT'S A QUESTION
OF HER HEIGHT.
KATE MOSS DID CHANGE
AN INDUSTRY STANDARD.
Tyra: CAMILLE.
Janice: "I-N" AS IN "IN."
J.: BLING-BLING.
Tyra: HEATHER.
Eric: WHEN I LOOK
AT HER HERE, I SEE NICKELODEON.
Tyra: SARA.
J.: I LOVE HER BODY.
Nigel: SHE NEEDS TO RELAX,
SMILE A LITTLE BIT MORE.
Tyra: BETHANY.
J.: I'LL GIVE YOU A CHANCE.
I SAY IN.
Janice: SHE NEEDS
TO HACK OFF THAT HAIR.
SHE NEEDS TO LOSE
A LITTLE BIT MORE WEIGHT.
Tyra: I'M NOT SURE
IF THAT FASHION GIRL
IS INSIDE OF HER.
Tyra: XIOMARA.
Eric: I'M SORRY, SHE'S OUT.
Janice: I THINK SHE'S IN.
J.: SHE NEEDS TO WORK
ON THE CAUGHT-IN-THE-DEER-LIGHT,
POSSESSED,
"CHILDREN OF THE DAMNED" LOOK.
Tyra: 11 BEAUTIFUL LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE TEN PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE TEN PHOTOS
REPRESENT THE TEN OF YOU
THAT WILL CONTINUE
ON THE JOURNEY
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
CATIE.
CONGRATULATIONS, CATIE.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Catie: THANK YOU.
Tyra: YOU'RE WELCOME.
YOANNA.
THE WOMAN THAT I SEE
IN FRONT OF ME IS EDGY.
SHE'S POWERFUL.
SHE SEEMS VERY CONFIDENT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Yoanna: THANK YOU.
Tyra: CAMILLE.
THE GIRL THAT WINS THIS--
I WANT HER TO LIVE THIS,
BREATHE THIS.
WE WANT TO SEE THAT WANT
AND THAT DRIVE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
APRIL.
MERCEDES.
SARA.
XIOMARA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
HEATHER.
I HAVE TWO PHOTOS LEFT
IN MY HANDS,
AND THE NEXT NAME
I'M GOING TO CALL
IS JENASCIA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL SHANDI AND BETHANY
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
Tyra: BETHANY, I'VE TALKED
TO YOU ABOUT POSING DIFFERENTLY,
AND IN THIS PICTURE THIS WEEK,
YOU KIND OF POSED
KIND OF PINUP-ISH.
BUT NO DOUBT,
YOUR FACE IS STILL GORGEOUS.
SHANDI...
YOUR PICTURE WAS GORGEOUS,
BUT YOUR RUNWAY WALK--
I'VE NEVER SEEN A RUNWAY WALK
THAT BAD IN MY LIFE,
AND WE'RE NOT SURE
IF YOU'RE GONNA BE ABLE
TO WALK LIKE A TOP MODEL.
I'M GONNA CALL ONE NAME.
WHOEVER'S NAME I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE LOFT,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS AND LEAVE.
Tyra: SHANDI,
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Tyra: THANK YOU, BETHANY.
Bethany: I DEFINITELY DIDN'T
THINK I WAS GONNA GO THIS SOON,
IF AT ALL.
I KNOW THAT I HAVE
A LOT MORE TALENT
THAN PROBABLY HALF
OF THESE GIRLS HERE.
IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING TO ME.
THIS IS SOMETHING
I REALLY WANTED.
♪♪♪
Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
HERE'S WHAT'S COMING UP
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
HEATHER STRUGGLES TO FIT IN.
Woman: It'll be all right.
Tyra: AND EVERYBODY
GETS A BRAND-NEW LOOK.
WE ARE GOING PLATINUM BLONDES.
YOU LIKE YOUR CUT?
Yoanna: YES, I LOVE IT.
Catie: (sobs)
Tyra: FEAR TAKES CATIE
FOR A RIDE,
BUT IT'S SHANDI
WHO CAN'T HANDLE THE PRESSURE.
Woman: SHANDI, OH, NO!
You shut up.